[Music]
if you thought sabrina carpenter's new
song
skin was a clap back at olivia rodrigo
song driver's license
she says you're missing the point i know
think about it
on sunday the 21 year old actress and
singer hit up instagram to address the
feud rumors pitting her
against the 17 year old disney star
posting
this pic and writing in part quote thank
you to everyone who has listened to skin
especially those who have opened their
minds to lyrically what i was trying to
get across
sabrina released skin late thursday
night
and naturally fans stormed twitter
suggesting that the song was written in
response to olivia's single driver's
license
which was released earlier this month
some fans think driver's license
is about the reported relationship
between olivia's high school musical the
musical the series co-star and
rumored ex-boyfriend joshua bassett and
his alleged new romance with sabrina
and you're probably with that blonde
girl
who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything i'm insecure
about but get this on sunday without
naming names
sabrina seemingly complimented olivia's
track
and straight up denied that her song's
skin was written in response
maybe we could have been friends if i
met you in another life
maybe then we could pretend there's no
gravity in the words we write
maybe you didn't mean it maybe blonde
was the only
rhyme they only rhyme
i wasn't bothered by a few lines in a
magnificent song
and wrote a diss track about it i was at
a tipping point in my life for countless
reasons
so i was inspired to do what i usually
do to cope write something that i wish i
could have told myself in the past
people can only get to you if you give
them the power to
and a lot of people were trying to get
to me and just in case you weren't
buying it
she doubled down and said the song isn't
calling out one single person
but rather several people and situations
that have impacted her recently
it's such a weird time right now
especially for like feelings are all
over the place man and that's all i
gotta say
is we are just all trying to figure it
out and figure out
how we're feeling and prioritize our
health our mental health our sanity and
um yeah i mean it's been it's been a
weird time for everybody okay
but she also kinda sorta seemingly
alluded to the alleged olivia drama
writing quote some lines address a
specific situation
while other lines address plenty of
other experiences i've had this past
year
yeah so there's that
[Music]
sabrina adds that a lot of things have
gotten under her skin
and she's still learning to not give
other people so much power
over her feelings but in a final effort
to call for peace and calm between all
parties involved in the rumored love
triangle drama
sabrina wrote quote i don't want this to
become an endless cycle so please don't
take this as an opportunity to send more
hate anyone's way lots of love to you
all
thanks for letting me grow